[Música]
al principio fue un intento loco de
hitler
y construir una línea de fortificación
sobre 4000 kilómetros a lo largo de las
costas europeas
[Música]
76 años más tarde administraciones
particulares y empresas tratan de darle
una nueva vida al célebre muro del
atlántico
en el finistère esta edificación
semienterrada alberga un museo habitado
por las voces de quienes vivieron bajo
el yugo alemán durante la segunda guerra
mundial
[Música]
y
es que
él es el creador de este museo oler ian
kelly
un apasionado por la historia que
recorre bretaña desde su infancia para
recolectar objetos y testimonios
al llegar a la edad adulta quiso
compartir su inmensa colección con la
mayor cantidad de personas y para ello
encontró el lugar perfecto
y aquí nos encontramos en el comando de
la batería de artillería más importante
del finistère este lugar dirigía el tiro
de cuatro cañones grandes que tenía un
alcance de 30 kilómetros es decir que
disparaban 30 kilómetros a la redonda
y ello impedía que cualquier embarcación
inglesa o norteamericana se viera
forzada a ingresar por el puerto de
pajares
una persona
que tiene la impresión de estar ahí hace
parte de nuestra historia bretaña y en
especial pérez con los búnkers que se
ven por todas partes en las playas usted
ya no
tienen que entender de dónde vienen y
que puedan ver lo que ocurrió antes la
calma de hoy en día está bien pero antes
de la calma hubo muchas aventuras de
nuestros bisabuelos
tiene que permanecer debe perdurar para
la historia para decirse que finalmente
fue hace menos de 100 años no se puede
repetir
no solo son los humanos los que se
apropian nuevamente de estos monstruos
de concreto en cabo fréhel la naturaleza
recuperó sus derechos
las fortificaciones que protegían la
costa se volvieron lugares de residencia
de los murciélagos
[Música]
pacificación para importación
hay que poner cuidado para no
despertarlo no insistir con mucha luz
para no perturbar los sol o tomar dos o
tres fotos que permitan hacer un
seguimiento científico a las poblaciones
presentes o fixo la propia nuestro peso
este murciélago ha vivido en cabo fréhel
desde siempre pero la presencia masiva
del hombre lo saco de su hábitat natural
que esta especie se refugió entonces en
estos bunkers abandonados
después un poco de paz y sólo que las
especies no podrían sobrevivir sin el
blockhaus en el cabo fréhel
costaría fortunas construir obras como
estas existen muchas a lo largo de la
costa y tan solo algunas cuentan con las
especificidades que pueden albergar los
dos y hemos detectado muchos murciélagos
a lo largo de la costa de bretaña y
francia que son objeto de un seguimiento
científico particular para preservarlos
en gloria no está base submarina
monumental es una de las construcciones
más impresionantes del muro del
atlántico
al final de los años 1990 la alcaldía
quiso valorizar este lugar instalando el
barrio de la vela justo al lado
desde entonces las escuderías de carrera
se instalaron en los antiguos alveolos
concebidos para los submarinos alemanes
estos vastos espacios que están
perfectamente adaptados para la
industria náutica
forma con el mástil más grande que
hayamos hecho ha sido de 54 metros de
largo y 5 toneladas
tenemos dimensiones evidentes que nos
permiten hacerle mantenimiento a todos
estos mástiles y fabricarlos es
sorprendente pero un poco estremecedor
decirse que hoy en día estamos en un
lugar que vivió de manera totalmente
diferente la re afectación de sus
edificaciones fue realizada como
consecuencia de nuestro oficio y los dos
están relacionados actualmente y a pesar
del frío logramos hacer cosas muy lindas
este proyecto constituye un gesto burlón
frente al nazismo así como los otros que
permiten recuperar estas fortificaciones
[Música]
un método entre otros para no sufrir el
traumatismo de la historia para mirar el
pasado de los ojos y crear algo más
grande
[Música]
i